we're pleased to have here on the Rich
Eisen show someone who made a quite a
decision yesterday and it certainly
seemed to be now based on what's
happened in the 24 hours since at the
forefront of making a sound decision on
behalf of Public Health and Safety the
executive director of the Ivy League
Robin Harris here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Robin I'm doing all right
how are you ready I'm hanging in there
what can you please walk me through your
decision-making and what led to it from
yesterday yeah this was a very extensive
process and a very difficult decision I
should say we know it was the right
decision but it was very difficult and
we have been involved in all sorts of
contingency planning for I would say two
weeks now as we have watched the
coronavirus or cope in nineteen develop
and spread and we developed within the
Ivy League office and with our athletic
directors all sorts of contingency plans
for the impact it might have on not just
our basketball tournaments but all of
our events and then as the situation
developed and it's been very very fluid
and as particularly in the northeast
cases started to develop and multiply we
had multiple conversations and phone
calls with the Ivy League presidents and
ultimately yesterday the president's
decided that regrettably the contingency
plans that we had been developing just
were no longer feasible given where we
were with campus policies that were
prohibiting large gatherings and it
would be inconsistent to then have the
basketball tournament that would exceed
those limits and so we made the decision
the president made the decision to
cancel the tournaments very thoughtfully
very carefully and understanding the
impact it would have on our
student-athletes and coaches who have
worked so hard for that opportunity
so why can't
and not hold them with no fans while I
make the decision to just flat-out
cancel the tournaments yeah that's
that's a great question and it's
something we seriously considered and we
actually had all levels of options as to
having some fans present having no
general fans and spectators present but
allowing necessary personnel maybe even
guests of the players and coaches and
even if you take out the guests of the
players and coaches and you have
necessary personnel and teams and all
that gets involved when you're bringing
8 teams to a campus we quickly exceeded
the limits that our institutions have
put in place for other events and the
way we approached athletics in the Ivy
League is that student-athletes are
treated like other students so it seemed
inconsistent to the presidents to have a
policy that applied to the campus at
large and then not apply it to athletics
so what about the concept of sending
Yale and Princeton on to the tournament
writ large where it appears they're
excellent question made that for all of
the winter sports where the seasons had
concluded the regular season that
concluded and to the extent teams and
individual to qualified for NCAA or
other postseason events each institution
could decide how to approach the whether
or not to approve that competition and
so those events are different than
bringing in a team to an Ivy League
campus and particularly to basketball
the NCAA provides charter airplanes
which is a different mode of
transportation than having to fly
commercially and so each institution
will have to make the decision whether
or not to send their teams or
student-athletes to the NCAA but the
presidents were comfortable because that
wasn't violating any campus policy
regarding large gathering interesting or
do you have any information as to how
Yale and Princeton is handling because
right now the NCAA is planning on having
the NCAA tournament in front of fans as
it's currently you and I sitting right
now about an hour after the World Health
Organization officially labeled kovat 19
pandemic right now as we are talking we
anticipate that both the Princeton
women's basketball team in the Yale
men's basketball team will be
participating in the NCAA basketball
tournament this has been a very fluid
situation I don't expect that answer to
change but I also know enough given
where we were a week ago that it would
be inappropriate for me to say there's
no way that will change right I don't
expect it to but I really don't know
okay executive director of the Ivy
League Robin Harris a few minutes left
with her here on the Rich Eisen show can
you share with us some of the science
you were told where you're like okay
this is what we've got to do some of the
science about social distancing and/or
community spread of this virus that you
heard and the president's heard and said
okay this is what we got to do can you
share some of that science with with
this audience sure I would be happy to
and obviously what our presidents have
been neat i ball deep really in
mitigating the spread of the disease
for as at least two weeks and have
consulted with various health experts on
their own campuses including experts in
infectious disease and we had the
benefit of an ad hoc committee that the
president's appointed to help guide us
for athletic policies so I too have
learned a lot in these in the past week
in particular and it's really about
mitigating against the spread and the
fact that even though as a population
students college-age students are not in
the high-risk category and it's
incredibly unlikely that they will be
very sick or you know the mortality rate
is quite low for younger people
they can easily become carriers and so
when you think about dormitory settings
or enclosed venues for athletic
competitions and the virus having an
opportunity to spread through droplets
as humans interact with each other those
individuals even though they may not
appear sick then become carriers that
could really detrimental impact those
who are more at risk the folks that are
older than 60 which is getting closer to
me every year and those with underlying
medical conditions and there's also a
concern about overwhelming the health
system by having an outbreak that
develops all at once so our campuses
have been implementing policies designed
to slow and the spread and mitigate
against the spread so on a couple more
minutes I have left with you here do you
think it's inevitable that for the time
being all sports leagues will come to
the same conclusion that the Ivy League
did you know I it's dependent
I think upon the particular situation in
the location where the conference's are
located and where the events are
occurring so for our campuses in the
Northeast seeing the cases develop in
Boston and New York and starting to
spread into some of the surrounding
states
our presidents felt that the they really
felt a great sense of social
responsibility to protect against the
spread in their own communities and I it
will be interesting to see if others
follow suit okay I appreciate you taking
the time I know your time is limited
before I let you go though just because
I got a and on somewhat of a different
note we had Jay Bilas on in our number
one was either one who was dragging down
the group GPA of the Duke University law
school class
I was a fellow student when Jay was at
Duke I wasn't privy to his GPA so it's a
great question Elton okay I just wanted
to just roll that one out there thanks
for the time I really appreciate it and
I hope to chat with you and much much
better times talking about some Ivy
League sports
thank you rich and take care you bet
that's Robin Harris the Ivy League
executive director here in the Rich
Eisen show